The Joe Rogan Experience you know what
they're doing out there right the people
in office you know well I mean Tulsa can
speak to that better than anybody I
don't I don't know
um mayor biss I may have met him in
passing uh but this has been one of the
big failures around uh the aftermath of
the Wildfire on Maui is this total
vacuum of of information from government
officials to the people and uh in that
vacuum obviously people have all kinds
of ideas or theories or this or that but
people were left without any kind of
communication from anyone in a position
of authority to provide help for days
and weeks and it created massive
problems and so you know uh the
immediate line of response needed to
come from the county and from the mayor
and from their emergency response
director and unfortunately uh they did
not communicate they're still not
communicating there's still a huge lack
of transparency and therefore an
increasing level of uh distrust in any
of the any of the levels of government
that should be bending over backwards to
answer questions and to say hey here's
what we're going here's what's going on
every single day here's what we're doing
here's what we're trying to do here's
what we're having a hard time doing
whatever the case may be it has just
it's it's been a major problem from the
beginning do you think that this is a
complete lie because of a complete lack
of preparedness that this is an
unprecedented type of disaster it never
happened before it happens and they just
weren't prepared they don't know what to
do and they're just it's incompetence I
think that that is very true
um and there's you know in hindsight
there are things going back as you know
Maui has experienced drought year after
year after year brush fires are a common
occurrence especially on the west side
of Maui where Lahaina is the the side of
the island that was most most impacted
by this
um you know it is you know being
prepared for wildfires on Maui is
something that if you look at their you
know emergency assessment documents uh
it's mentioned almost as as a bit of an
afterthought Maui fire has been vastly
under manned and under-resourced for
quite some time so there's all these
different things you can look at from a
preparedness level that that should have
been addressed long before but from uh
you know the you know the county
officials uh yes they were completely
overwhelmed and unprepared for this
unprecedented Wildfire it's the worst
Wildfire our country has seen in over a
hundred years
uh but the problem is once you get to
that point like oh this is really
really really bad not only in in the
hundreds of lives lost in that fire but
the surrounding communities of people
who who
survived but who went without power who
went without any cell phone signal any
ability to communicate with people who
didn't have you know all of the gas
stations in their neighborhood they were
empty there was no way to get gas they
couldn't get food they couldn't get
clean water the water supply systems
were contaminated I mean all of there
there was disaster upon disaster that
came in the aftermath of the fire that
went unaddressed and my biggest I was I
went there a few days after uh the fire
happened Maui was my district for eight
years when I served in Congress and I
had a lot of friends there and went out
to those affected communities and what I
heard over and over again was no one
from the county the state or the federal
government has shown their face in our
community it is Neighbors helping
neighbors families helping families
people on the island of Molokai which
you know they they don't have much on
their Island everything comes in by
barge they're loading up whatever they
have in their General Store on these
little votes and and running them over
to West Maui on a private boat dock
because that was the only place that
they wouldn't be blocked from bringing
food and water and medical supplies now
why are people being blocked I keep
hearing that about people being blocked
is it because they haven't gotten an
accurate death count is because they
have to make an assessment of how much
was damaged and it's so Matt massive
it's so vast that they haven't been able
to do that yet like why is it being
blocked things are things so things are
being opened up now I think people are
able to to get in and out of the West
Maui area I understand that the
the historic town of Lahaina is still
being blocked off and they're they're
working on reopening it as we speak but
in the in the couple of weeks after the
fire
I don't have a good answer why they
continue to block the roads
again to those surrounding communities
why they had why they blocked people
like Kai Lenny and others from using
their jet skis and boats to try to bring
supplies in through the water
um you could say well we were trying to
secure the area but you're blocking
you're blocking friends and family from
coming in and bringing necessary
supplies literally doing Supply runs so
you know I I jumped on a plane that was
doing Supply runs from Kahului the main
airport on Maui uh out to this tiny
little airport
that serves that community and that was
for a lot of days the only way that they
could get supplies uh brought in I don't
know I I really don't know but again
this goes back to why aren't you
communicating to people what's going on
and why you're doing what you're doing
all all the results of their decisions
left people and families and communities
stranded in their most dire time of need
and the mayor didn't go out and show his
face until almost two weeks after the
fire happened that's insane it's crazy
and then says he wants to take the land
for the state that's his first now this
is I think the governor
about this like how is that possible
that these people could lose their home
and then lose their land
like how is that possible it is it is
the number one concern of people there
uh in Lahaina is that a few days after
this happened
I haven't spoken to the governor
but he said in a press conference he
said we're talking to the attorney
general he said I'm talking to my
attorney general to explore options for
the state to take over
that land and use it to build Workforce
housing or build a memorial to the lot
for the people who lost their lives but
the fears that the people in Lahaina
have some of whom like Archie kalepa
famous or for Community leader native
Hawaiian leaders families lived in
Lahaina for nine Generations
now being told well the state the
governor is looking at taking that land
taking ownership of that land
that
it is unconscionable and there's oh you
know we'll we'll you know for those
who've been displaced we'll see about
doing a land Swap and we'll send you the
big island to live in Puna Jesus it's
taking away the sovereignty of people's
rights to have a say over their home in
many cases their generational lands is
is uh it is such an abuse of power and
so this is and I'm I'm glad that there
are leaders in the community who are
leaning into this fight to make sure
that they're fighting this fight before
anybody tries to do that rather than
looking in the rearview mirror and
saying gosh I wish we had done something
but just imagine
a governor going on television after a
massive tragedy where you have we don't
even know the number of people dead yet
you have this massive area that's from
birth to the ground yeah and then he
starts talking about taking it over from
for the state that's an insane position
to take it is post-tragedy when people
are suffering at their most they can't
even believe it happened yeah and then
all of a sudden he's saying we're gonna
take it for the state and make a
memorial how about give the
people their homes back exactly one of
the things we went over yesterday
which is a crazy number we were looking
at the amount of money that was
accidentally sent to Ukraine like they
they over sent 6 billion and then I said
well how much would it cost to rebuild
every house in the Maui fire and it's 5
billion five billion something yeah like
they that's just like accidental money
but there's no talk doing that there's
no talk of doing that is that
interesting the way the way and it had
it's happened two or three times now
where the Pentagon has said oh we
miscalculated how much money we had set
aside for Ukraine so we have an extra 4
billion to send now that we didn't know
we had and this has happened a few times
Secretary of State Tony blinken went to
Kiev yesterday promising hey we're going
to give you another billion now and this
is the thing when I was out there in
Maui
person after person was like Tulsi
tell me what would happen if we started
to call ourselves Ukraine you think they
would give us some money then to take
care of our families to put to fix our
roofs you know that have been torn up by
the hurricane winds that came through to
make sure we have clean water to drink
you think they might pay attention to us
then and then the and then FEMA comes
out the FEMA director comes out and does
this press conference I think it was at
the White House and she says well
someone said well what are you doing for
Maui she's like oh
we're giving a one-time 700 dollar
payment to everybody who's been impacted
by the Wildfire a one-time 700 payment
it's insane Hawaii has the highest cost
of living in the entire country the
entire country and how freaking
insulting is it to have the represent
the lead Disaster Response administrator
from the Biden Administration stand
there and proudly say hey we're giving
everybody one seven hundred dollar
payment
it's insane and it's insane especially
because of how much money we're sending
to Ukraine yeah because there's there
can be no doubt these things are
financially motivated now